mark meadows is the chief of staff over
at the white house we're happy to have
him on
tonight mr meadows thanks so much for
coming on so i have to ask you
about the continuing violence in kenosha
it has reached a point where people are
getting hurt
huge amounts of properties being
destroyed i mean it does seem out of
control why is this being allowed to
continue
well it is out of control and it can't
be allowed to continue tucker you're
exactly right
obviously i got a call today from the
congressman that represents that
district from senator johnson as well
really just pleading for help said that
the local sheriff
and mayor and police chief need some
additional assistance so i got on the
phone right away
and and called the governor and offered
assistance in in the form of additional
national guard help uh as you know
they're going to have some additional
national guard there tonight
but you've got a as a governor and as as
elected officials you've got to either
ignore the problem which a lot of
a lot of liberal governors are doing
exactly that they're
ignoring the problem or you have to deal
with it and
and consequently uh when you deal with
it you have to make sure that you have
enough
uh people on the ground to to not let
the rioting go you listen we have a
first amendment right
that allows you to peacefully protest
but you do not have a first amendment
right
to loot and to riot and and what we're
seeing on the streets of kenosha
uh really just breaks our heart uh the
president was on the phone with the
governor today as well
uh we have uh national guard standing by
that that if the
the general for the national guard needs
additional help
we're there to do it but today that
request was denied by the governor
i i just keep thinking and clearly tony
evers wants
riots he's the governor of wisconsin he
should be ashamed this is a moral state
in my opinion but i keep thinking
if these were right-wing protesters and
they were screaming
racial epithets and intimidating
democratic voters
the department of justice civil rights
division would not allow that to stand
for three months do you think they would
why are they allowing this
i honestly don't understand well i can
tell you that as we've gone in there are
a couple of things that have happened
behind the scenes tucker
you're right to have called it and
called it out not just here in kenosha
but in portland you've been covering
that on a regular basis
no we've made uh over 99 uh
actual arrests in portland but here's
the interesting thing is when you go in
and you've got a local d.a
in portland that is where they won't
even arrest people and if they arrest
them
they let them out the next day it's just
a perpetual problem that you have
and that's why when we when we look at
it we have to do a number of things
federally the president has been very
clear with me
very clear with the attorney general
enough is enough it's time to make sure
that we restore the safety
of those communities setting up a task
force to make sure that there are some
of those federal arrests
that that i just mentioned but even in
addition to that is making sure that we
have additional federal resources so
the appeal tonight to the people of
kenosha is the president is willing to
help
it's time that we uh take control and
hopefully
the the the number of national guard
that they have in tonight will actually
restore
peace but i'm not uh i'm i'm not
optimistic
oh boy what a tragedy mark meadows
thanks so much for joining us tonight i
appreciate it
thank you tucker good to be with you